Nicole is in Lancaster Pennsylvania
Winchester if I said that right Nicole
what's up how are you better than I
deserve how can I help okay
so my husband and I are going to be
getting a pretty significant tax return
or something maybe ten grand or so and
we have a couple different decisions to
make and I wanted to get your opinion on
this so we just paid off all of our
debts except for our mortgage which is
about eighty eight thousand dollars way
to go thank you
but now my husband also has a business
partner and they have some rental
properties in an LLC which have a
significant amount of debt as well and
we have the opportunity to possibly the
one is an 11 unit which there's like
five hundred and forty four thousand
dollars on that one and there is a
personal townhome which has about 75
thousand on sat.1 and we have the
opportunity to possibly so get out of
the business and get out of the 11 unit
and just take on the townhome as our
personal rental property then mm-hmm so
that's one situation right now do you
need money to do that well we wouldn't
have money to cash flow that no so that
would become our debt you know I'm
saying you need to use the ten thousand
dollars in question no question with the
ten thousand then is if we would do that
would we put ten thousand towards
starting to pay off that or I also need
a vehicle I have a 2001 Chevy Suburban
right now it's probably worth about
three thousand it's rusting really bad
and there's some unknown engine issues
those really deserve our showroom to
them my husband makes about 86,000
before taxes okay and you're a
stay-at-home mom I'm a stay-at-home mom
we have three kids you have an emergency
fund yet we have our one thousand dollar
emergency fund we do not have the
shortest
month 1 gotcha ok alright well it's
pretty simple we're going to walk up the
baby steps and before I buy cars couches
or vacations I have I'm debt free except
the home and I have an emergency fund so
if you need an emergency fund before you
buy a car and 10 grand yeah so that 10
grand is going to be you're raising your
$1,000 up towards your three to six
months of expenses it's going to take
that whole 10 grand easy
and that money's just gone there and
then you start saving aggressively for
your car you might have it might even
not start your baby step 4 15% of your
income going into retirement for a short
period of time and until you save up 5
or 10 grand and buy a car
ok if you want to do that I might do
that as far as the other rental property
goes you pay it off with your house and
baby step 6
okay so just lump that into that yeah
dump dump that over to baby step 6 and
clean it up as you're cleaning up your
other real estate real estate goes in
maybe step 6 and I all real feel yeah
unless it's a tiny tiny little own or
something revealed fifteen thousand or
something and then end up being sixty
okay the last question is why in the
world are you getting a tax return of
ten thousand of dollars Roz if that
means you're withholding $800 a month
too much right yes well my husband was
self-employed and he just at the end of
last year in September started a new job
so that means that that means that
either their job is over withholding by
a bazillion or he paid out too much into
his quarterly returns one of the two I
think both is happening and he already
is looking into adjusting what he's
getting back because yes we are getting
a lot he's getting way too much taken
out yeah yeah you need probably in this
case you probably just need to have your
tax advisor calculate your actual tax
bill for 2019 and set your withholding
up to be that tax bill okay and you know
take the proper note because the number
of date
of deductions that you take has nothing
to do with reality the IRS can't do math
so their deductions chart is completely
screwed so you need to figure out we are
going to pay $12,000 in taxes so we need
to withhold $1,000 a month we get paid
twice a month that's $500 a month a
paycheck or whatever right just do some
simple math look at the total tax bill
divide it into the number of paychecks
and make sure that you claim enough
deductions to get that amount withhold
and not much more okay
our goal is to get a $50 refund or less
Wow
because otherwise you're loaning money
to the government all year at will no
interest they don't pay you interest
Santa Claus does not live in Washington
DC that was your money you gave them too
much and they gave it back to you with a
wink and a nod and you feel like
Christmas came in April but it doesn't
okay so that's that's where you want to
be with tax refunds but anyway you're
doing great
that becomes your that becomes your
emergency fund and then we save up and
buy you a car and then we start baby
step for 15% of your income going into
retirement five is kids college and six
is other extra money's we get later on
we start going towards the houses and
begin to get them paid off in that order
so good question